this is grandma savara kobian and today
i will be showing you one of my games
and this is a thursday evening class
with the saint louis chess club
and welcome everybody and i hope you
will enjoy this game okay
okay let's take a look here so d4
knight f6 this is a game i played long
time ago
in in uh many many years ago in the
king's indian defense
my opponent is a russian grandmaster
nikolai kabanov
and here i want to show you how you're
going to play against the king's
indian defense so g6
knight c3 bishop g7
so at the moment here we don't know
which opening it's going to be
is it going to be the grunfeld or is it
going to be the king's indian defense
okay so he decided to play bishop g7
so we have a king's indian defense now
knight f3
castles and i play bishop g5 this is my
favorite system against the king's
indian defense
this is called smithslof petrossian
okay so here let me show you a couple of
things the opponent can do here
they can play d6
sometimes they can even opt for
immediate c5 here
in that case you play d5
h6 is a possibility but then we go
bishop h4
so d6 we play e3
now he plays c5
idea to put pressure on d4 so here white
has two options here
you can choose to play b2 if you want to
or
you can play the immediate d5 if you
play bishop b2 you're gonna be
you know basically ready to play this
position
bishop d7 castles knight c6
then we have a position where i think
white doesn't have much advantage
you know bishop f3 rook c8
b3 so i mean white will try to claim a
small advantage
because of a little bit better control
of the center but in general i think
it's just going to be
pretty balanced here i have played this
positions before as well
but my favorite move is d5 i feel like
this is the most
direct way to play
so now he plays h6
questioning my bishop
bishop h6 pitch page four now he plays
g5
g5 putting pressure on the bishop on g4
bishop goes on g3
and now he plays knight h5 so black is
committing all these weaknesses with one
effort
with one idea to try to pick up the
bishop
on g7 now we have a choice here what to
do
we have to develop our light squad
bishop or we have to try to move the
knight
so i decided to play the move bishop d3
and in this game my opponent played e5
but let's take a look at this move here
what if black
plays let's say knight d7 in this
position
what kind of tactic do you see here that
you can try to do here
because he did not trade on g3 right
away
which is a mistake because now he's
giving us an opportunity
to go for the tactic knight takes g5
if you take with the pawn then it goes
queen takes h5
now threading mate on h7 and also
threatening to pick up the pawn
on g5
so if he takes on g3
h takes g3 now if he doesn't take on g5
i just simply retreat with my knight and
then i'm very happy
i'm up a pawn so he takes
now we go bishop h7 check forcing the
opponent king to go to h8
and now knight f6 is a very important
defense
for black so he wants to play knight f6
so what we need to do here so we have
control of the f6 square here okay
we need to have our own piece
controlling it
and that move here is the fantastic
knight e4 the fantastic knight e4
now he goes for example knight f6
we simply capture
he takes queen h5
now the idea is to play bishop g6 check
and queen h7 mate
bishop g6 check and will be a queen h7
mate
he can try to give a check on a5 but
that's not going to do much i'm
simply going to play king f1
and now ruko is on let's say e8 or
something
or he can maybe do this in this position
try to get
escape squash and now what do you do
here
what would be your option here do you
want to move the bishop to do a
discovery check
or do you want to go for something a
little bit stronger here
what would be something a little bit
stronger here of
course that is the move queen
takes f7 queen takes
f7 and now we are ready to move the
bishop away
and announce the mate so let's say he
goes here
bishop d3 check here
rook h6 is a mate
okay
so that's why um after queen h5
in this position white is threatening to
play bishop g6 check
and queen h7 mate with a mating attack
so that was the game i played i actually
did this tactic in australia in 2008
against uh i think uh i want to say a
video master 2200 player
ivassian you can find that game probably
in the mega database
it's from 2008 tournament in australia
so but this opponent didn't fall for it
he played
the move e5 but
this is also a blunder here by
international master
kabanov why why is this a blunder here
what can you do here that will show that
this is a blunder here
now he is losing material here
now he's losing material
so what we need to do here is
we play well let me let me give you a
chance here i'm going to open up the the
youtube chat
and see if i can see your comments here
okay
so think of think about it what should
what should i do here
okay what should white do here
now what can you do in this position
guys
so i'm gonna look at the chat to see if
you have some ideas here
why why e5 is a mistake
let's take a look chess king queen h5 is
suggesting
better knight e5 i don't know siddharth
siddharth sato
knight e5 yes he has knight g3
d takes this is brendon villa brendon
villa
d takes e6 correct brendon
now the question is if he takes back
bishop e6
what are we going to do now
if he takes back with the bishop now we
have a tactic here
what is the tactic here guys bishop
takes d6
hitting the rook rook goes on e8
bishop c5 winning two pounds
and if he goes for example bishop d6
queen takes d6
now we have a beautiful check on h7 he
has to take back
queen takes d6 okay
so that's why he
when i played dtx6 he he didn't do that
he realized the problem that he's losing
so he took on g3
but when he takes on g3 now
i take back with the pawn if i take back
with the pawn he has bishop e6
so here guys where you have to play a
very important
very important in between move here
what's that in between move here we can
try to do so we can win some material
what is that in between move here guys
that we're going to do here to win
material
absolutely chess king take on f7
takes hd so now let's take a look at
this position here
correct brendon villa so now what is the
evaluation here
we're up upon here okay but what
you know is it winning or it's still a
big advantage here
so let me know in the chat chat okay
what do you think here
yeah now uh i'm up upon and also his
light squares are quite weak here
after rook f7
so i decided to take back hg and now he
plays knight c6
and now my first question to you here
how should i try to proceed
in this position okay of course i can
try to castle i can do
something like that but something better
here something better here you have
so what can you do here
now i i want to try to bring my bishop
to d5
this is what i'm trying to do
so i played the move bishop g6
now he played rook f6 attacking my
bishop
now the bishop is under attack but now
the bishop rookies at least on f6
is kind of blocking the bishop so i opt
for
bishop e4
now he plays bishop e6
now he plays bishop a6 and now we would
like to trade
the light square bishops here how we can
try to do that
what would be the logical move in this
position guys to try
to trade the light square bishops here
winning advantage guys but you still
have to convert it okay
you still have to convert it it's not so
simple okay
so here we are going for the move bishop
d5 correct
brendon villa see that's at all
correct bishop d5 josie correct
absolutely we're trying to trick trade
the light square bishops okay so bishop
d5
now he goes queen d7
now he goes queen d7 now he wants to go
along castle uh he wants to bring the
rook on f8
and put pressure on f file my king is
stuck in the middle of the board
but i decided should i get my i should
get my queen developed to d2
now rook af8 and now i have to make a
decision
do i go long castle or do i go short
castle
what do i do here so i have a question
for you guys
why to play is it a long castle
or this is the short castle in this
position
is it the long or short castle here for
white
long siddhar sato short team chess
kill long castle
chess king short
well i mean if you go long castle
obviously you're taking a little bit
more chances
because he can play something like night
before and try to put pressure
yeah so yeah i
i i didn't see a big issue so i decided
to go long
shortcuts i decided to go short castle
here
and now he goes king h8 now after he
plays king h8 he is no longer
tied up and can try to move his light
squad bishop
to g4 or f5 so i'd now want to have
my opponent have the pair of the bishops
so that's why i took only six
queen takes the six and now now we know
one thing when we're ahead we're ahead
material we want to try to go for the
trade here right
so here i i knew that he's not gonna
trade but i thought okay
at least i can activate my queen
proposing the trade he goes queen e7
if he trade it's just a hopeless
position down upon in the end game
so he decided okay i should keep the
queens on the board
27 now what do we do here
what is our plan now guys
what is our plan right here
if you look at the position and ask
yourself a good question here what
should white do here
how should white try to proceed here
so rook fd1 correct team chess attack
the d-pawn i like that one team chess
rook 81 okay
rook 81
rook e6
um rook 81 rookie six
and now i had to make a decision here
which it wasn't so simple
but i had to do this because i was kind
of stuck
i was kind of stuck i didn't i could not
see a way
that i can try to proceed here
how can i improve my position so and i
realized that i need to make some
adjustments to my position
so i played queen d2
so now i can play knight d5 and also
finally i can play the move b3
so here goes queen b7 queen f7
b3
and now after b3
he plays a6 idea behind a6 is to stop
knight b5
so i cannot play knight b5 but now
what should white do here how should
white how should i
try to play for a win here
even though i'm up a pawn but it's not
so clear if there is a
you know clear plan here
i decided to play knight d5
activating my knight and now it's
already getting serious queen h5
played and now there is some potential
take on f3 like rook takes f3
pawn takes f3 knight e5
now what to do he's he's gearing up
after queen h5 and he just wants to
sacrifice on f3
what's the idea here let me look at the
chat to see if you guys can find it
what's the idea here
now what can we do here
now what to do against this okay
now what to do
he wants to take on f3 and then he has a
95 idea coming in
position is getting really really
complicated here
so i did not want to allow rook takes f3
i did not want to allow rook f3 so i
played the
very modest knight h2
now he goes queen g6
now yeah i mean i can try to play for
like
f4 or something but i wanted to be very
safe
and solid here i thought if i can trade
queens here
this might be a good opportunity
yeah so this was my idea to try to trade
queens while i can and try to just
keep my minimal extra pawn advantage
here
so i proposed queen d3 i was expecting
he would probably play queen f7 or
something like that probably queen f7
because if he goes to e8
there is a fork okay
so i was expecting that he will do that
so but after queen d3
to my surprise
he just took i took played 95
now rook t2
rook d2 and now he played the move
g4 fixing the
f3 square and trying to prevent
me from pushing my f pawn
now after after g4
i played rook fd1
now he goes rook d8 and here i would
like
to see the plan from you guys what would
be the plan right here
what is the correct plan
yeah i agree my opponent didn't play the
very best way
i agree
now doubling up the rooks right
so rook t2 g4 now what to do here
my knight on d5 looks very nice but it's
blocking me from attacking so i play
knight f6
knight f4 rook f6
and now very very important move here
for white
let me look at the youtube here see if
you guys can find this idea
what is the idea here we need to attack
the weaknesses sedan
sedan sato correct
team chess jonathan andrews
yeah if you play this move then he's
gonna lose more pawns more material
now what's the move here
to try to put more pressure look at that
rook on d8 you're putting a lot of
pressure now
on this d6 a lot a lot of pressure
so let's take a look here
the move is rook d5 correct
rook d5 correct because we're
threatening to take
we're threatening to take on c5 we're
trying to take on e5
okay rook d5 is correct
and now immediately
after rook d5 he decides to move rook to
b8
sacrificing another pawn now how many
attackers we have on
d6
yeah so now take rook takes d6
actually uh looks like after he played
drug b8
now knight h5 first
take
and now rook takes d6 now he plays
rookie seven now we're up
now we're up a lot of material here
we're up uh
two pounds so but let's try to win this
very quickly
yeah now g4
now the idea is to bring this knight in
neither for back king h7
and now this whole time his knight only
five
has been very very superior
now his strongest piece is the knight on
e5 right
so i did just to play knight d3 to trade
them
now if he takes i was expecting to take
back with my d1 rook
but instead h5 was played
protecting g4 and now
what is the correct move here after
which
i win this game
now threaten to take on c5 as well
so now he played h5 and now
just knight takes c5 and
white white went on to win this game
okay
a very interesting position a lot of
complications
but at the end it all came down
to the safety of the king
there's page four g5 this is the game
once again
and they try so huge if black doesn't
want to fully to any of these chops
he should play knight takes g3 then i go
h takes h3 and then play e6
this should be the best way to play
there we can play bishop e2 we probably
should
do and now the threat is to play queen
d5 okay
now queen d5 and now we have some
threads on h7 so let's say knight h6
a3
and now i have this queen d3 idea now
threatening to checkmate and this will
really weaken the position
quite a lot okay
so we went here he played e5 and when he
played this room this came as a surprise
because i played this position for many
many years
and i've never seen black play the move
e5
you know but it looked kind of
interesting because now he wants to play
f5
he wants to be very very aggressive with
f5
now we take once again
if he takes on g3 that's the game we're
going to take on f7 so and if he takes
with the bishop
if you're just joining us here guys what
is the tactic here
if you're joining us what is the tactic
here
to win material
now what's the idea here
now we have bishop takes d6
he goes here bishop takes c5
okay so that's the idea so he went up
and up to take on g3 and now i took on
f7
takes and now white is just winning
material
okay all right very good that was
excellent now we're gonna do a couple of
tactical positions for you guys okay so
again this game was a game acobian
cabanov from 2000. all right
all right let's do some studies okay for
you
all right perfect
okay
all right so i want to give you some
time to think
i want to give you some time to think
okay
white to play and win
here the king is quiet weak on h6
you have to go for like a forcing ideas
here
think for just a second i will check the
chat right now
what's the idea why to move yes
now you have to calculate quite a lot
here
you have to calculate quite a lot in
order to find
the right idea
so please write down your answers in a
chat but you have to calculate a lot
now what to do here i see an answer from
chess king i see an answer for a gaming
queen f6 check correct
now he goes here king h5 then what do we
do
then how do we follow it up here
so check
now what do we do here
bishop e3 check correct
forcing the king to go back on g7
now
we we we cannot make the king on g7 we
have to try to force him
to go back
queen g5 check
now if he goes to the corner
if he goes to the corner this is going
to be a mate how guys
how is this going to be made guys if
he's in a corner
we have to use the bishop
now if f6 bishop takes f6
okay
if he goes here
check
and winning the queen
so that's why he's not going to go to h8
he's going to go to
f8 now king goes to f8 now what do we do
here
how we're going to continue here guys
now what to do here it seems like yeah
we can give a lot of checks here but
what would be the right follow-up here
what would be the right follow-up here
bishop c5 correct ay gaming
now if he goes here mate
correct so it has to go here
bishop d6 and now it seems like he's
holding everything together
but the question is is he really holding
everything together
or it just seems he looks like it okay
is he really holding it together or it
just simply looks like it
now what is the special move here
now bishop c5 check he goes bishop d6
and it looks like he's holding it so
which idea we have to play here
queen h6 check uh unfortunately
he goes k7 and he's protecting
he is protecting the bishop here in fact
we have to be careful we're down a lot
of palms
so
if i've seen the player who is winning
sometimes you know
lose to it because if you make a wrong
one mistake then they defend
all right let's see here juan lungo 25
chess king
correct 25 thomas absolutely
absolutely guys queen e5 now what is
this idea called everybody
cross pin right you're pinning him and
then you bring another piece so that's
called a cross pin
okay pin
and cross pin okay
[Music]
now he goes here
queen 2d8
now what's the follow-up here i still
want to see the cross pin
correct correct chess game
pinta kill tim chess how how do
bishop d6 check now he goes to a8
then what do we do
now check change it and now what do we
do
now what do we do
okay team okay queen g3 checked him
but he goes here
now we go here
now he cannot go anything so he has to
play f6
he absolutely have to play here and if
he does that what is the idea
now what is the final touch in this
position to win
guys
okay
now what is the final touch idea here
that we're going to use to win it
queen g5 that way we're pinning
that way we're pinning the bishop
you know bishop is pinning the king on
this diagon and now the queen
is pinning the queen so if he takes the
key he cannot take the
queen it's going to be a problem now
bishop f6 is just
win so he has to take here
and then we simply take
and we just up a queen so we will easily
win this
so idea for this position guys is to
remember for you it's called
the cross pin okay the cross
pin remember that so let's start from
beginning so we had one cross pin right
here
when we played queen
yeah we played queen to e5
that is cross pin number one
crossing the queen and a king and then
we reach this position which is going to
be
cross pin number two
cross pin number two because again you
cannot take the queen
because the bishop checking and you
cannot take the bishop because
the queen on d8 is checking as well
okay you have to remember your end games
guys
you have to remember your cross pins
okay perfect all right
and now at the end we're gonna do the
last position for today guys
excellent play excellent play today
everybody on the game
i'm watching the chat and excellent
excellent job everybody
okay
all right
white to play and win
the problem we are experiencing here
he's threatening to play
c1 queen check and threaten to take on
d2 as well
he's threatening too many things okay
so what can we do in this position
to to manage to win this okay
thank you alex thank you appreciate you
like the class
absolutely studies are very important
siddha
sedan okay
studies are very important and that's
why i i put a lot of emphasis
on for my students to do lots of studies
okay i put a lot of emphasis
okay and now what do you do here
why to play chess king think about it
okay don't rush chess king
you're rushing with your answers
don't rush
okay there are two threats here we need
to acknowledge that there are two
threats
there is c1 there is take on d1 okay
thank you alex i'm enjoying i'm enjoying
working with you everybody
and i like i appreciate that you you
like the class so much
thank you for the compliment
so what's the first move he has two
threads he has c one thread
he has c takes the one thread so what is
the our idea
what is our idea
broke the egg check okay rook the check
is the correct start
now if he goes to c1 the task is easy
you just simply play php2
takes there are no other moves
now takes sorry
and rook takes don't take with the
bishop because if you take with the
bishop you're gonna accidentally
still made your opponent okay you don't
want to do that
you take and then you simply go here and
convert this into a win
so that's why he's not going to go to c1
he's not going to comply
he's going to go here
but now what to do he's still
threatening the same two threats okay
he's still threatening the same two
threats of taking on c3
and taking on d1
taking on you know d1 and also play the
pr
playing c1
now what do we need to do here we need
to lose our own knight guys our own
knight
is causing us the problem here okay our
own knight on d1
is our obstacle so we want to try to
lose it
so we play rook d a check
if he thinks we will be happy because
we'll give a check
here we go here controlling it
if he goes here bishop d3
and just simply take on c2 okay
so he's going to go here
king 2d2
and now is the critical moment this is
the main reason why i chose this
position today
because here you have to find a very
special move here
very special move very special idea
i want to give you a little bit of time
to think so you can
sink in and find the right idea
okay i see one correct answer so far
if you go king a2 just take
not going to be able to win this okay
rookie two i'm not sure because rookie
two the problem with rookie two is i
think
he just simply plays uh king takes
okay
mm-hmm
yeah king rookie just simply takes
you know so he's not gonna he's not
gonna go to c1 okay
he will take only one it's going to be a
draw here
no if you go king b2 i mean i can play
c1 queen
i mean this is this is not going to
solve our problem sequence with a check
you might need to be careful not to lose
this now
so right here we have to do something
there is no choice here guys for us
we have to allow him to get a queen here
paolo azevedo
knight c3 correct
the point being here if it takes
i go here check
if he goes here i have bishop d3
if he goes here i have king b2
okay so that's why
he's gonna play c1 queen check but now
it looks like completely
insane we allow him to have a whole
queen how are we gonna play this
position
that's okay we have a solution here we
have a solution here guys
and that is what is the move here
what is our solution
knight b1 chess king team chess correct
now if he plays
uh rook c1 rook c2 you have a nice check
rook ca check picking up the queen okay
so you cannot do that
so you cannot go here he can echo d3 e3
so he has to go here
king to d1
okay so he'll just place king to d1
and now what we're gonna do here we're
so close here
we're so close here but we need to put
him into that mating net
and that is rook d a check
correct now he cannot go to the c file
because we have rook ca check
king to d1 and we can play bishop p2
to make life easier takes
you win the rook and you win the game
okay
so that's why he has to play
king to e1
now he plays king 2e1
and now we give a check because we push
him only one
and for a moment it seems like he's
escaping but
is he really escaping no he's not team
chess
absolutely he's not escaping rook f8
and now we are threatening unstoppable
mate
and look at this remarkable the knight
here is restricting the squares
and right is restricted squares and it
cannot go anywhere
so rook f1 and it's going to be a mate
unbelievable study guys let's go over it
one more time
so rook d a check if he goes here it's
just bishop b2
so he has to play king to e1
check if takes it's just rook d8 winning
king d2 and now knight
c3 takes
check so rook ca check and king b2
so that's why he had to go c1 and then
we promote he promotes to a queen check
he goes back
check if he goes to c value rook c8
wins and if he goes to
e1 we simply play rook f8
and unstoppable mate on f1 okay
thank you much thank you very much
everybody for watching this
and thank you for your participation
and i will be back sunday evening sunday
actually sunday afternoon and evening
for some more classes for you okay so
make sure you tune in
and i will see you on sunday okay
everybody goodbye
bye